[Music]
and welcome back everybody we're going
back to Laredo Texas now recapping day
three of Ronald Virgo sevillas's capital
murder trial the former border patrol
officer faces the death penalty in a
double homicide that prosecutors allege
was over child support money Virgo
sevillas was married with his own
children when he had a child with 28
year old Griselda Hernandez in an
alleged Affair in March of 2018
Hernandez reportedly served the
defendant child support documents at his
workplace and a month later police say
the defendant ask Hernandez to see their
almost two-year-old son and they set up
a meeting in a remote area near a park
prosecutors believe the defendant
stabbed Hernandez and that little boy to
death on that visit to avoid paying
child support on Tuesday several border
patrol officers testified about
responding to the crime scene after the
defendant called 9-1-1 they said the
defendant's behavior was strange Virgo
sevillas apparently didn't mention no
the victims in a times was suspected of
contaminating the crime scene by
removing Footprints and moving the body
of Hernandez the defense challenged the
officers by pointing out inconsistencies
from before and after Virgo sevillas was
identified as the prime suspect on
Wednesday he witness testimony came from
Elizabeth Stevens a digital staff
engineer at Motorola she testified about
the location of the defendant's police
radio around the time the prosecutors
believed the murders happened
that is the location at the timestamp
okay
and
this one right here that's the second
location of that time with the 1010
timestamp so this right here is from
1010 and then this one was the 9 949 the
one prior to it yes okay
and these are the where
a power down cycle occurred
yes and would that be the data that was
stored
would be a waypoint stored on this radio
right yes
the GPS coordinates don't tell you warm
yesterday Thunder or any of us what Mr
Bluegrass was doing in that area at that
time correct correct or not all of the
coordinates that the device received
during that period of time correct what
I don't know is
there were any erroneous
GPS locations that were not
um
were not available
at the time of shutdown you hear the
defense fighting up against that Brian
what'd you think of the witness I mean
did you find the testimony the evidence
really damning or was it just
circumstantial
I unfortunately I'm gonna give you a
lawyer answer both right and this is why
there's direct evidence in the
circumstantial evidence it all works on
a scale it can be very deep into
circumstantial evidence territory or
very close to direct evidence and I
think the cell phone information is very
close to direct evidence that is damning
what I think this really does is it's
the prosecution almost moving in chess
piece and saying check not Checkmate but
check because now the defendant has to
come up and say this is why I was in the
area and it wasn't Criminal it almost
forced them to have to testify because
otherwise there's no other explanation
other than he is the murderer just
really bad coincidence I mean Nicole
just because someone's near the side of
a murder doesn't mean they had anything
to do with it if you were in the defense
seat what questions would you ask under
cross-examination
I would definitely be asking all kinds
of questions about the science behind
that GPS a location that you know in the
device that we all carry around on our
cell phones the witness has to really
understand the math and the towers that
are available so that when they are
telling a jury they can tell a location
for a person carrying the phone they
have the science to back it up and right
now I would be asking questions about
that science it's it and it's this
police radio how accurate is that Brian
it really depends on the technology
within that um County or District the
NYPD which I often cross-examine I
notice respect they probably have better
technology than most law enforcement in
the country so it depends on who you're
asking and what their resources are and
that that would be an interesting line
of communication as well across
examination as well talking about the
technology itself and how accurate it is
well when we come back the man seen on
video choking a homeless man to death in
a New York City subway car enters a plea
in court the charges he's facing that
could create multiple opportunities to
find him guilty
[Music]
welcome back to Long crime daily
everybody Daniel Penny the Marine
veteran charged with choking a homeless
man to death on a New York City subway
car pleaded not guilty in court
Wednesday morning penny is charged with
second-degree manslaughter and
criminally negligent homicide so that
means that a jury could find Penny
guilty of acting recklessly or
negligently he's free on a hundred
thousand dollars bail and he'll be back
in court in October Penny choked
homeless man Jordan Neely on a subway
car at the Broadway Lafayette Street
Station at least two other passengers
helped keep the victim down Penny held
nearly in the Chokehold for several
minutes and a medical examiner
determined that's what caused his death
now Neely had a history of mental
illness Witnesses told police that Neely
started shouting in the subway car about
being hungry and not caring if he
returned to jail or even died but those
Witnesses also say he was not acting
violently when Penny suddenly intervened
Penny insists though he had no choice
New York's train system is dealing with
a spike in crime and what MTA is calling
a bad couple of weeks but officials are
assuring the public that crime is still
down overall last week there were
several stabbings and slashings on the
subway and a man was shot in the thigh
but according to officials the number of
felony assaults and murders is down this
year compared to last so far in 2023
there have been
152 felony assaults and four murders
hundreds of officers have been deployed
to help keep crime down but the exact
number changes depending on who you ask
so Nicole Penny's defense says that the
looking for people who understand the
dangers of the New York City Subways to
be part of that jury how important is
jury selection in this case
you can win a case or lose a case in
jury selection so it is one of the most
critical phases of trial and being able
to ask questions of the veneer is so
important for the lawyers trying in case
it's good the lawyer is thinking now
about the types of individuals or jurors
he might want to hear the facts of this
case
Brian we knew that the ma about the
manslaughter charge we knew about this
idea of recklessness but talking about
the jury now there's this other charge
this criminally criminal negligent
homicide break it down for us what
exactly that means and what the jury
would consider all right so manslaughter
in the second degree is the highest
charge they did not give uh Penny an
additional charge at the same level or
higher but it's actually a little bit
lower so we call an E-class felony he
could do no jail time to up to four
years but what does it mean to be
criminally negligent when it comes in
New York state it means that you'd fail
to perceive or see an unjustifiable risk
and you commit an act that has a risk of
the danger the danger here being death
and it goes further to saying that type
of risk is what some of us reasonable
people those imaginable people would not
do and you have as what's called a gross
deviation or you're just far out in left
field from what we would all agree is
say and so it's really to say I made a
mistake that I didn't really know about
but should have known and everyone else
knows unlike recklessness where you knew
it was a mistake and you still went and
did it it's just a lower standard of
knowledge and it gives them another
option and Brian real quick 30 seconds
you want Subway Riders on your jury
if I'm a defense attorney I do not want
Subway Riders because I think the people
who don't ride the Subway have a greater
perception of danger in it than the
person who goes on it every day so it
really depends on what side you're
arguing New Yorkers versus let's say
tourists different perception of what
might be weird and different in the city
Nicole Brian thank you so much everyone
out there thanks for joining us here on
Long crime daily we're going to see you
next time as we discuss Justice in
America
foreign
[Music]